in teoria questo dovrebbe essere un
video di halloween tol.org halloween è
già passato e due non fa un cazzo di
paura è allora che vide merda bello e
più ti ragazzi benvenuto questo video
sono fa vj suoi calci siamo tornati sud
veri organized tempo siccome halloween
c'è anche la versione natalizia di the
very organistiche quel gioco dove devi
rubare gli oggetti in casa venezia tanto
lo sapete già tutti nudi che sto
spiegare però c'è sempre qualcuno che
arriva in ritardo e non lo sa che è alex
trucchetto che in italiano alex
tronchetti
adesso la vostra vita è migliorata
insomma sapete tutti chi l'ha fatto
la versione diallo mi chiama ragnatela
che figlio la versione di halloween e
più [ __ ] di tutto del gioco normale che
le cose che devono fare ragazzi sono
scritte su questo coso ciao ragazzi
cercando di capire un attimo cosa devo
farla l'ormone da trovare le cose
cristofaro oggetti da prendere in
prestito certo la cosa che mi piace di
più di tutte è che la maggior parte
delle robe che ci sono scritte che non
le so tradurre quindi meraviglioso
spiegami perchè dovresti rubare un
frullatore ma non un tablet che voglio
capirlo se avete un po di piante nel
cannella calderone
ecco esatto cosa si che cazzo stokr e
amen tablet i tablet così esce un
mutante social
perfetto allora non trovate un oggetto e
ragazzi tutti quelli che devo trovare
fantastico a1 cielo tra casini che cazzo
come a piove porca eva i raggi non avevo
visto era di nuovo visto dai ragazzi sto
diventando brutto stop di gatto è finto
un gatto figli va a fan culo
sono stato ucciso dal reapers toma zio
solo the reaper celeri c'è la morte
ragazzi tenebra quello di billy e mandy
prossimo tra mi nascondo dalla morte
anzi li faccio vedere il mio iphone
l'iphone grosso io metto qua davanti
così almeno quando entra controlla
facebook che anche la morte cia facebook
non mi caga di strisce ognuno ha le sue
tattiche ragazza arriva la morte a un
certo punto quindi devo muovere il culo
prima che la morte mi uccida prima si
sono fatti j
la cucina che che cazzo devo ammettere
questa cosa qua dentro si no si sa che
cosa minchia servi cos'era qualcuno deve
darmi delle spiegazioni ematomi strano
sto gioco nel periodo di halloween
troviamo le cose prima che che finire
alla barbecue laptop che sarebbe questo
qui è giusto non questo tablet
mi serviva anche il tablet perfetta
eccolo eccolo ho trovato frullatore ce
l'abbiamo ma ora mi trovate perfetto ce
l'abbiamo anche quello che abbiamo tutto
queste cose che sto rubando mi
renderanno miliardario e cioè avete idea
da barbecue in garage in gravi barbecue
ecco le prime che genio percorso
mettendo gli oggetti nel culo loro bando
in casa della morte se vi sembra logico
la morte usa e ketchup
non sono stato io ma solo tipo un gatto
l'impegno che cazzo è florida sedie alla
scocca prossima volta che provi a
lanciarmi in aria e françois 21
ok di aria via via via via via via via
via arrivando una stanza quella [ __ ]
tipo di più di veloce della cia c'è
standard sono un gatto miti ecco fai la
guardia bravo bravo io mi nascondo
nell'armadio perfetto ragazzi è arrivata
la morte tanto c'è la sedia di sotto
tutta la forza di goku ci sia un iphone
grosso che una sedia davanti alla porta
non entrerà mai c'è un braccio dentro al
mio armadio è un armadio dentro il mio
braccio non scherzo [ __ ] dove albe
scusi signora io sono faringei stava
rubando in casa qui fatte entrare nella
stanza che sei più alta della porta le
regala un orsacchiotto che tenga in casa
nostra è andata a paura però non se n'è
andata non vada via non ci passa dalla
porta l'assenza le ho regalato un
orsacchiotto le regalo una zucca forse
ho trovato un modo
no no no la starda sì sono io vivo
prendi la sedia triumph sprint dove si
vola via via via via via via via via via
via veloce veloce la cena chiusi lì che
ho letto non mi troverà mai io c'è una
falciatrice nota non ci credo ma lei la
casa più bella se metti i fantasmi e
ragni sul muro e te lo dico ecco la
digital camera [ __ ] a non è serio
media che strano caso è
straordinariamente quando avanti magari
si caga in magazzino trovava il caffè
porto come lo struccante è posto a
diffuso ragazza il cappello veloce dove
minchia lo tieni un cappello
nata a ubriaca di sei stata tu e anche
incazzati casa tira un vino del chianti
46 bucato un buy in di sidi buona lui
dai cin cin cin cin prendi bicchiere
brand ha chiesto prendi il tuo proprio
niente festività nel ruolo devo trovare
il bollettino delle password quella
merda sedia porca [ __ ] la sedia grazie
a dio mica ti sei servito a qualcosa non
ci posso credere [ __ ] c'è un'altra
stanza eccolo 6 1 4 1 per fermare vai
vai vai aprile e abbiamo trovato la cosa
perfetto perfetto ragazzi ho trovato la
cosa ad ora mi manca solo così vi vanta
il tostapane che non c'è certo stavano
introvabile ma si va con contro la
moquette osta bagno le cuffie bar a
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
halloween vedi che anche alla morte fa
gameplay la morte può infatti vedere un
video di cat mario è convinta di farlo
c'è un problema non trovo trovo il pane
ma non trovo tostapane vaffan cuore
forte se gambe mi farò i panini senza
sosta ecco come ho fatto non ci sono
orbo ragazzi abbiamo tutto dopo ore e
ore di ricerche incredibile prendo
l'ultima è col cetriolo consigliere
infilo [ __ ] tutto tu lo frate
e niente buona continuazione ho vinto
non soccorrere 16 minuti e 45 secondi
per finire stack agata cioè rendetevi
conto che no un'ora a trovare il
tostapane ragazzino nov la roma è
stavolta più veloce visto che so già
come si gioca
silver candace tx dai veloce veloce dove
lo cerca il gatto saltato provare il
gatto spiegatemi perché in bicicletta
perché la bicicletta già cielo vino raro
perfetto direi che siamo
eccolo questa rai va in fantastico
pensavo di avere uno rossonero nella
merda multiplayer è questo
insomma un xbox il gatto dove mica è non
lo so può essere ovunque non è come ai
mito beni gatti ragazzi datemi in oscari
quando entra la morte non è manco
trovarmi via se riesco a farlo in tempo
prima che arrivi la morte mi dovete dare
il premio oscar nelle cuffie sono quali
fissi minchia lei messe recuperano
quadri eccole ragazzi oggi sono harbor
non vedo un cazzo non so perché ecco la
scatola di gioielli così tutto nel
trovare solo il gatto queste camera va
assorbito 66 29 perfetto che minchia che
fenomeno ragazzi si trova il gatto vinto
tanto come prima ancora che arrivi la
morte è fantastico e atto gatto di merda
il gatto di me 26 lurido che felino
eccolo non ci credo vito c'è un serio
si è passati dalle 17 minuti quasi a
quasi tre minuti record d'accordo
ragazzi che un crudo che l'episodio
spero che anche se è uscito un po in
ritardo vi sia piaciuto perché la vocina
da lui è bello che per ogni festività
cambino il paese il paesaggio
l'ambientazione avete capito italiano in
questa frase fa più paura di qualsiasi
maschera di halloween vedrete in up in
questo halloween ragazzi concludo che
l'episodio spero che vi do vi sia
piaciuto e cosa i ragazzi se video è
piaciuto al momento è un mi piace anche
al pacha di facebook che come nei video
tornare l'edizione zero se dovessi
distretti che ci vediamo al prossimo
video buon halloween a tutti ragazzi